it's not really about what happens at
the end of the race it's really having
the courage to show up and to start and
to look at something that seems really
impossible but to break it down and not
only do it but also enjoy it and find a
new part of what I'm capable of
I worked at a hedge fund on Wall Street
for five years and I realized at one
point that I really needed an outlet I
felt like I was in a job where you know
my passion really started in the morning
when I was out riding my bike or running
or talking to people about it later in
the day for me my definition of balance
is that there really isn't balance
because I like to be 100 percent driving
toward what I find most fulfilling and
where I feel like I can make a
difference
I am the women's product manager at
specialized so my mission is to bring
more women into the sport of cycling at
the core I'm responsible for really
managing our women's product line all
designed to fit women and give women the
most enjoyable experience possible out
cycling when I meet women who are
curious about cycling one of my biggest
tasks is just to really spark that
curiosity and to bring them into a sport
that has really defined my life in so
many ways and is a passion that I live
every single day I was the youngest
woman to run a marathon and all seven
continents so that included 26.2 miles
across the Gold Coast in Australia
Florida and North America Brazil and
South America Dublin in Europe Mount
Kilimanjaro in Africa the Beijing
Marathon in Asia and then of course the
clinical experience which was the
Antarctica marathon way down at the
bottom with earth ultimately I think
when I finally got the record it had
been a quest for over two years and I
was so excited about it and so
passionate about it and I remember
getting the certificate and kind of
being like oh that's nice and what I was
really excited about were the people
that I met along the way
sort of memories I had of these places
and it just really opened up my
worldview in a way where when I got to
the end of that road the record was a
nice piece of paper but the process was
really real out of the learning happened
I thought that was one definition of
challenge
and the ironman opened up a whole new
world and Ironman is a journey that
takes you from a lake to a bike to a run
and every high and low in between and
there is something in the suffering of
Ironman and the communal suffering that
really pushed me forward it's been a
goal that I trained for and it's also
been something that's defined my life
it's a way that I like to live it's more
than a race it's an experience and a
lifestyle for me I don't think I could
do it unless I really enjoyed the
process readings on atop the Blue Nile
Gordon one of the things that I asked
myself a lot is what's next I decided to
apply to Stanford as a way to transition
into a fitness focused career that was
based more around my core passions I had
four months before I had to be at school
and what better way to fill four months
than to ride a bicycle from Cairo to
Cape Town so I entered the longest
bicycle stage race in the world I left a
great job great apartment great life in
New York City got on a plane to Cairo
almost walked up and asked the pilot to
turn the plane around and I didn't want
to go but as the plane was descending
into Cairo I realized that I was
embarking on something really special
I took a different route out of the GSB
the many of my classmate my opportunity
at specialize was very unexpected I came
in to this wonderful place with all
these bikes and people who love to bike
and after five years in finance it's
been just a really exciting new
challenge to work on products and to
work on products that I am personally a
very passionate about was great for us
as people that are passionate about
cycling right not that they like to bike
they love to bike and know how much of a
life changer it can be for people so
when we met Aaron that passion for
cycling but more importantly her drive
and determination in everything that she
had done in her life it was like well
she's fantastic
I don't think I could do my current job
without the two years I spent at the GSB
coming into an environment where
feedback is very direct it comes from
all over the world like the GSB
empowered me to prioritize my time to
listen to feedback and to really have
the ability to step into leadership
I think I've followed a very unusual
path I think it's just a part of my
philosophy which is always asking what's
next and always driving toward whatever
is around the next bend and not being
afraid to step into something very
uncomfortable for me it's the next
Ironman the next bike ride that's just
sort of moving forward constantly and in
every possible direction